thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies quantum mechanics is best
explained when you can
judge your audience in real time so i
thought i'd come at this a different way
than usual
by trying to explain it to my wife if a
person is not experimentally measuring
it
then what is a measurement very good
question
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
i guess first off what do you know about
quantum mechanics to begin with
good question not much i took intro
physics
in college and then i've been you know
with you
for a while i mean it comes up
occasionally
when we're talking and whatnot quantum
mechanics has to do with
probabilities and things i don't know
appearing and disappearing and
and tangling and sure i don't know i
think that's
i think it sounds pretty typical okay
basically
the idea is that particles or at least
the behavior of particles is described
by
waves now we don't necessarily mean the
waves that
you're used to thinking about like nice
wave
shapes on water or something it's a
little more abstract than that
a wave is just a solution to a wave
equation
equation and we've decided that
something like schrodinger's equation is
a wave equation and so even though
there are solutions to it that don't
look like traditional waves
we call them waves anyway you kind of do
this in physics where like you're we're
going to use the word wave but it's not
a wave it's the same thing that you do
with spin
right yeah it's not spin nothing's
spinning but we're gonna use the word
spin and we're just gonna go with that
very very simple solutions to
schrodinger's equation do look like
waves but it's
it's not universal sure but it's not
universal for physics does it even
matter
that's fair fair complaint so they're
described by
waves but what's really going on is like
you said it's a probability thing so
the solutions are what we call
probability distributions
right and so they're just i'm nodding
like i'm like yes probability
distributions i understand what that is
right no no these are words that i know
what they mean but i don't know what
they mean together in this context yeah
so we're all clear on this so yeah so
the probability distributions now those
distributions they can be distributed
over
lots of different properties but usually
it's
across space like position location that
sort of thing so you get maps like
atomic orbitals and stuff the things you
usually see
um when we talk about the probability of
an electron
as long as we're not observing it right
well we're going to get to that okay
this this is going to be very important
for today today's topic
okay
when we have this wave model that
describes how a particle exists or what
how you know how it's behaving or how
it's going to behave
we often say that the particle could be
in multiple states simultaneously which
is is a gross misinterpretation or
misrepresentation of what quantum
mechanics actually says which you know
what we'll probably get to in a future
video
it's just that the states of these
particles they don't exist
like normal things exist
welcome to quantum mechanics right here
we are and so things are just weird
they're weird
i'm sure it can be difficult to
understand and explain
to the normal population that only has
that
only has normal like science to work
with
you know what i mean if things don't
exist the way that we expect them to
exist i'm
sure that that's very confusing for the
rest of us right
so we say this this particle exists in a
superposition of states
but that superposition is one state it's
not multiple states it is
one existence for that particle
it's just that that existence doesn't
make classical sense
right it's that superposition is a
combination of multiple
classical states the kind of states that
we'd expect a ball to be in
i mean i feel like you're really
splitting hairs though
to say that like well it's not existing
in multiple states at the same time it
is existing
in one state that is all of the states
at the same time
i mean right well it's it's a real
actual single state
that is a combination of physics states
that we would
understand pre you know relativity and
quantum mechanics
but what quantum mechanics has shown us
is that there are
other single states that exist that we
don't understand
okay so not even talking about
superpositions or we are
no we always what we're talking about a
superposition is
a single state that just doesn't make
sense to our
our eight brains is it like four
dimensions if you will how like we get
three dimensions
when we start talking about higher
dimensions we just really struggle with
like
understanding what that's like and how
that works yeah that's that's exactly it
so so these particles exist in a way
that violates our intuitions
there's one major problem and it's
called
the measurement problem okay quantum
particles can behave
in a couple different ways okay
there's a very nice steady controlled
way
which is when the wave form
evolves over time it changes over time
very gradually according to something
like schrodinger's equation
the other possibility is we take a
measurement
now the word measurement has some
ambiguity to it
okay it seems to imply a person needs to
be involved and there needs to be an
experiment which is not necessarily true
if a person is not experimentally
measuring it then what is
a measurement very good question
i would say that a measurement is any
particle interaction
that releases information about a
quantum system to the surrounding
environment
now that environment might be a lab with
a person in it but it doesn't have to be
is this similar to like if a tree falls
in the forest does it make a sound
type of thing like it produces sound
waves even if no one's there to hear it
like this produces
information even if no one uh gather it
not exactly future nick butting in here
for a minute
her analogy about the tree making a
sound is actually much better than i
gave it credit for while we were filming
now that i'm editing the video i
realized i was a bit too dismissive of
it and i wanted to point that out
okay back to the conversation i just
we're trying to define a measurement
like this so that
quantum mechanics doesn't sound like
magic right
it's not like human beings are looking
at the situation and we're like
we're going to look at this and see what
it's doing and then it changes like
we're not affecting
the physics of the problem right of the
of the experiment it's just
happening because of like the way that
we're measuring it
in order to measure something about an
electron we have to do something like
shoot photons at it okay and it's the
photon
that's making the measurement happen not
the person so that measurement would
happen if a person shot the photon or if
the sun shot the photon
exactly is the point here exactly as
long as those circumstances took place
for that electron and photon interaction
it's considered a measurement
okay again with like using words
yeah don't mean what we think that they
mean the problem we run into what we
call the measurement problem
is that even if a particle like an
electron is in a superposition of of
states
a superposition state i should say right
because it's just one state
right it's just one state if it exists
in a superposition state
if we look at it if we try to take a
measurement try to shoot photons at it
we will not see that superposition we
will only see
a single classical state one of the
parts of the superposition
it's like it collapses yes uh in fact we
call it
wave function collapse got it
and this is a big problem mainly because
this
collapse this wave function collapse in
order for it to make sense
it has to happen instantaneously so it's
not a gradual
shift right and so because it happens
instantaneously and we know from our
experience with the rest of physics that
nothing happens instantaneously
right that it's a major problem okay
is it a problem or is it just the way
that quantum mechanics works and you
just have to accept
that that it's this is a weird science
that does not
act the way that you expect it to act
that is a way that some people handle
this
but not a way that everyone handles this
and so which way do you handle this
oh uh we'll get to my personal opinion
later okay
quantum mechanics sort of brings to
light
a discrepancy in how people view physics
sure we like to view physics as though
we're finding some deeper understanding
about the universe
but it's not really what physics is
about physics is about making
predictions
okay right we want to be able to science
is about making predictions right right
well exactly so this what we try to do
in physics is we try to come up with a
model
that's going to predict future behaviors
of things
right so in this case quantum mechanics
is
predicting future behaviors of quantums
or
you know little quantum particles right
okay it allows us to make
accurate predictions correct using this
branch of science right all right
i'm gonna stop the conversation there
before this turns into a 45 minute video
if you want to hear us chat about
interpretations of quantum mechanics
let us know in the comments and i'll
upload the rest of the conversation
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to supporters
like medic hurts
who's pledging at the asylum orderly
level on patreon
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy if you
want to learn more about quantum
mechanics
you should try out the quantum objects
course available on brilliant
it starts out teaching you how quantum
measurements are made
when you're ready you can move on and
learn all about the mathematical
foundations
brilliant is a website and app that
makes learning accessible and fun
their courses are laid out like a story
and broken down into pieces
so you can tackle them one bit at a time
and there are over 60 courses to choose
from so there's something for everyone
brilliant helps you achieve your goals
in stem starting with one small
commitment to learning
and building up to long-term challenge
and growth
if this sounds like a service you'd like
to use go to brilliant.org science
asylum today
the first 200 subscribers will get 20
off an annual subscription
you forgot to yell about conservation of
energy i forgot a lot of things in that
last video but if it makes you feel any
better
conservation of energy shall not be
violated and thanks for watching